the uk says it's poised to impose
tougher anti-covered measures as the
infection rate their
spirals with more than 7 000 infections
registered in 24 hours
there is only one way of doing this and
that's by showing a collective
forbearance
common sense and willingness to make
sacrifices for the safety
of others and i have to be clear that if
the evidence requires it
we will not hesitate to take further
measures
that would i'm afraid be more costly
than the ones we put into effect now
one week ago the prime minister boris
johnson now brought in a 10 pm curfew
for pubs bars and restaurants in england
similar restrictions were introduced in
scotland and wales along with a 15
person limit for weddings
the uk government also introduced a rule
of six meant to simplify and strengthen
the rules on social gatherings but as
kate partridge reports
it led to more confusion
the uk is suffering from covert 19
confusion
rising levels of coronavirus infections
are causing widespread battlement among
the public and officials
struggling to implement the policies aim
to defeat it even the prime minister
mixed up some new restrictions it's six
in
in in a home or six in in hospitality
but
as i understand it not six outside but
boris johnson got it wrong and had to
tweet an apology
apologies i misspoke today in the
northeast
new rules mean you cannot meet people
from different households in social
settings indoors
including in pubs restaurants and your
home you should also avoid socializing
with other households outside
that couldn't go unmentioned by the
opposition leader who seized on his
rivals gaff
to highlight public confusion about
exactly who's supposed to do what
if the prime minister doesn't understand
the rules and his own council leaders
are complaining about mixed messages how
does the prime minister expect the rest
of the country
to understand and follow the rules the
prime minister is also facing opposition
within his own party
with some slamming the new anti-coveted
measures and especially their hasty
implementation through parliament as the
death of freedom
when you've got a body of law that large
changing that fast
i doubt really anyone understands what
that law is
this is not a fit environment for free
people how do people think that liberty
dies it dies like this with with
government exercising draconian powers
without parliamentary scrutiny in
advance though others think the policies
don't go far enough
one conservative mp thinks the military
should oversee any
potential mass vaccination and then
issue certificates for international
travel
i have written to the prime minister
recommended recommending that he
consider
calling on the ministry of defense to
establish a small task force
led by a senior empowered voice of
authority
to begin the planning and design of a
draft
blueprint the armed forces have the
capacity
the logistical experience and the
national reach and are not overburdened
by
any current duties involving tackling
kobit 19.
while parliament itself felt the wrath
of public opinion when it was revealed
the bars in westminster
were exempt from the new 10 pm
hospitality curfew
a loophole that was swiftly closed
following the indignant backlash
one rule for them and one for us no
wonder the country is ignoring the 10 pm
curfew
this whole party is corrupt in
everything they do
instead of being shocked about
parliament's bar not closing at 10 pm
shouldn't we be asking why parliament
needs a bar
no wonder mps keep doing u-turns all the
time
alexander defel and his new cabinet
enjoying the paint after 10 pm at a
private table
in the houses of parliament bar watching
orwell's animal farm unfold in real time
is really something
the uk has heard several anti-covered
government mantras
stay at home protect the nhs save lives
was a guideline people could understand
but the rule of six prompted the
question which six
and even flummoxed the prime minister
confusion
has replaced clarity which also begs the
question
can the government expect the public to
follow the rules
if they're struggling to explain them or
even agree on them
kate partridge rt london
you